[Music]
c'mon he was the rock-and-roll poet
laureate of Canada this week the music
world suffered the expected yet still
heartbreaking loss of gored down
[Music]
[ __ ] fronted the tragically hip one of
Canada's preeminent rock bands for more
than 30 years ladies and gentlemen from
Kingston Ontario it is my honor to
introduce to America my friends that
tragically
while the band enjoyed some success in
the US the hip as they were known
reached legendary status in their home
country in part due to their enigmatic
frontman and his songs which focused on
the history and spirit of Canada
[Music]
the hip one Canada's Graeme the juno
award 16 times the most of any band in
history they also received the Order of
Canada and even had their own postage
stamp I thought I was going to make it
through this but I've known it hurts
Canada's Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
wept in Parliament this week while
speaking about Downey's death he loved
every hidden corner every story every
aspect of this country that he
celebrated his whole life and he wanted
to make it better he knew as great as we
were we needed to be better than we are
we are less as a country without gordoni
in it Downey was diagnosed with terminal
brain cancer in late 2015 but he led the
band out on a farewell tour of the
country the following summer culminating
in one final show in their hometown
Kingston Ontario
[Applause]
while the venue held only a few thousand
people the hips last show was broadcast
nationwide nearly 12 million Canadians
about a third of the country's
population gathered from Halifax to
Vancouver to say goodbye in Gords final
months he continued to make music and to
push for change a fierce advocate for
uniting Canada's native population he
was honoured at an assembly of First
Nations gathering alongside Trudeau in
what he would call the greatest day of
his life
[Music]
it's been said it was like losing Bob
Dylan and Springsteen in a14 Canada it
meant that much but at least they got to
say farewell and dead he was a national
treasure
sure was